hallo mein name ist lukas meine lieben
freunde herzlich willkommen wir heute
mal wieder zu einer neuen eye tracker
reaction auf zur holzschuh ende in der
letzten folge waren wir an der stelle
stehen geblieben dass sich corey
aussuchen durfte mit welchen mitteln er
auf ein date gehen möchte der hat sich
für francesca entschieden die allerdings
mit harry ein bisschen amrum flirten ist
es ist interessant heute eine tier ohne
die regeln auch so dicke die hochzeit
also das ist falsch es gab und es ist
harry und dieser komische kreis ist der
eye tracker der zeit wo ich hingucke
laune und mit den hochzeitseinladung
noch etwas warten
francesca sie weiß es ja noch gar nicht
sie bekommt das jetzt erst mitgeteilt
dass sich corey für sich entschieden hat
die sache ist halt dass corey die ganze
zeit mit chloe also unserer lampe amrum
schalkern war allerdings hat er jetzt
auf die frage von lana mit welchem
mädchen auf ein date gehen möchte sich
von chefs entschieden und ich weiß noch
gar nichts von ihrem glück oder von
ihrem pech und ich bin auch gespannt wie
harry hat reagieren wird wie du weißt
hilft euch euer aufenthalt ihr tiefere
verbindung aufzubauen und sie können
auch getestet werden
auf einem date erwartet ich habe ich
dann haben den flugzeug was startet von
kari und harry denkt sich auch so dass
harry und corey in der letzten episode
to how to handle auf die ich hier
reagiert habe auf meinem kanal noch ein
richtiges brau gespräch hatten und wegen
brockmann klärt sie nicht die mädels von
freunden anscheinend korrekt ist nicht
so ernst genommen ich habe heute morgen
geraten spaß zu haben
das hatte ich damit nicht gemeint aber
ich habe keine sorge ich weiß wie schon
gestern
kurz noch mal für dich zur info harry
francesca hat in der letzten folge mehr
oder weniger chor einen heiratsantrag
gemacht
sie hat ihm gesagt sie steht auf ihn sie
hatten hamas teil er riecht gut er sieht
toll aus der tolle muskeln tolle tattoos
und der harry ich meine
rugby reduzierung so stark ist wie ihr
glaubt sollte das kein problem sein
auch wieder die sache es halt ein test
für die beziehung trotzdem einig mädchen
hätte und sie wird mir sagen hey ich dir
jetzt mit einem freund was essen ist
aber wirklich nur ein freund würde ich
mich auch fragen hey wenn der freude
auch noch danone mal heiß aussieht das
finde ich gut weil talk mit und zu weit
wenn man weiß was kories absichten sind
ich weiß ich sollte es nicht mal in
erwägung ziehen weil ich meine inneren
triebe bringen mich dazu
[Musik]
von ca
hatte bisher mit hey lieber sie
kurzzeitig zum shaker das sogar mit ihr
in der regel gebrochen sie hat mit harry
regeln gebrochen sogar mehrmals
sie war mit ganzem world wurde und jetzt
entscheidet ist ja auch noch über ein
date mit gori francisco hast allein von
den 50.000 verlorenen euro geführt die
hälfte auf sein konto zu verbuchen
das ist zu stellen gute nur lama will
mich testen
kann das auch verpacken hell harry wir
verstehen uns zwar gerade voll gut aber
das ist voll der heiße bei und ich muss
dass ihr testen
hier sitzt auch im haltverbot der ball
sollte ich auch reagiert das kann ja
warum aber echt warum harry du musst
doch wissen was das für eine ist
alter schwede labbadia wir ihn ab immer
wenn ich den abhör muss ich und
servierten bänke und dann kriege ich
direkt hunger lust haben dass die den
vista passiert nichts ok wenn er nicht
glücklich
die war wirklich aber ich bin auch ganz
hin und her ich bin voll auf deiner
seite bruder eigentlich kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen dass da was passiert
weil die ware nach der show zusammen und
wenn da was passiert wäre dann wäre ich
an harrys stelle nie eine beziehung mit
ihr eingegangen aber wir haben vor jazz
café kennengelernt über sieben folgen
das wird ziemlich schwierig jetzt jemand
muss das ganze jetzt noch glory
beibringen
[Musik]
und da hat die arschkarte gezogen
ja auch noch die zu beginn bei der
action bereits gesagt oh ja die ganze
zeit mit glow amrum tourten also mit
unserer lampe und jetzt hat sich das
versprochen von corey und garantiert
nicht für sie sondern für franceschini
nada beziehung ist und mittendrin ich
will nicht in ihrer haut stecken
das war corey okay das war schon gut
[Musik]
sieht nicht so aus als wäre das schon
gut ehrlich das ist einfach kann es ist
einfach kam aber sie preis so ekelhaft
abserviert hat danke corey dass er hätte
mir sagen müssen dass er nicht mehr will
das ist nicole die hatte bisher mit
niemandem was eigentlich gar keine sind
dass sie dabei ist francesca und corey
haben null an stand ja das stimmt leider
und wenn francesca und corey
zusammenkommen würden das wird
irgendwann so enden wie hat diese ganze
gerda beef sache
glaube ich so schätze ich die da alle
ein nein ich meine das ist ein problem
für ein scherzkeks auch nicht francesca
realtech francesca du hast echt ein
problem und
dann finde ich sollte man wirklich
arbeiten und das können wir hier in köln
bei mich in schwierigkeiten bis mir das
blut aus dem mund
das endet nicht gut ich sag's euch
freunde das habe ich nie gesagt das hat
audi gut gehen was denkst du gerade
[Musik]
wie konnte harry dich als freunde danach
dem stellt euch mal vor ihr habt eine
person die ihr mögt und die person hat
euch auch gesagt dass ihr euch mag und
ihr habt gesagt hey wir mögen uns
gegenseitig und keine ahnung was man
fleißig ist diese person eine andere
person dann plötzlich die ganze zeit am
proben turteln über worte
ich hoffe du machst jetzt keinen fehler
aber ich finde so irre wie mich das hier
mitnimmt ich hab damit einen scheißdreck
zu tun
ich hatte dich von anfang an im auge
aber dann war klar da läuft was mit
harry und ich wusste nicht ob ich einen
vorstoss werden sollte ich an seiner
stelle hätte es auch versucht sie sagt
ich an der stelle hat es auch versucht
das heißt
bisher
also heißt doch so ist es für einen
juden kann es nicht lassen einfach so
ich bin total durcheinander ich mache
nichts ich gehe nur mit dem was essen
bord bis zu attraktiv du bist so heiß
und es waren ihre ersten beiden sätze
schied die abwehr schiesst sie einfach
ab wie lange warst du single und das
zählt jetzt nicht mehr
[Musik]
er ist nicht einfach francesca
entweder von diesem date oder wenn du
dann noch länger bleibt es dann verpiss
dich bitte aus der schoah die arme lampe
und erbe harry stellen die beiden wir
jetzt auf ein date geben harry und chloe
dann wird sich francesca wahrscheinlich
auch so denken
es ist ein ernst
harry hatte mit keinem anderem edel was
in dieser schule tut mir echt leid was
hat die überwindung gekostet mich so zu
öffnen
das war einfach zu krass für mich
natürlich auch richtig so
einfach richtig so ich hätte dich nicht
zu einem date eingeladen wenn ich
überzeugt wäre dass das ernst mit die
meisten
er redet sie aber auch daraus die ganze
zeit mehr das ist schon krass wieder
davor bricht was harry und ich haben es
zu reserven ich glaube nicht dass ich
sowas nochmal finden und so rust ich
versuche nach ist warum sagst du die
ganze zeit doch nicht noch mehr ohne
jungs mal dass er so quin tiefsten kommt
er verstehe sie nicht aber wieso haben
wir kein geld verloren
meine lieben freunde denn an der stelle
würde ich die heutige reaktion auf tour
zu ende jetzt auch beenden wenn es euch
gefallen hat das geld einen daumen hoch
unter dem video hier da und dennoch kein
teil der lupus liegt auf abonnieren
das mega verpasst ihr so was wir wissen
dass hier nicht mehr in zukunft werde
man kann doch nicht abonniert habe dann
könnt ihr hier oben einfach mal ganz
kurz auf dem zwei die draufklicken ist
kostenlos und die bereits gesagt
verpasste dann meine tollen videos nicht
mehr hier oben sind ja auch meinen shop
eingeblendet und gibt es merchandise von
mir zu glauben die cpb und hier meinen
letzten action of portal verlinkt da
seht ihr noch mal wie das mit dem data
alles überhaupt zustande kamen